sixty-four alright folks see a lot of
your starting to come in we're gonna get
started in just a little bit I'll let
the room fill up first good evening
everybody a lot of more people still
coming in so I'll just give a few more
minutes and I say good evening sweet
baked in New York for the meetup is but
I know we're pulling people from all
around the world so if I say good
morning or good afternoon or good middle
of the night I hope everyone's covered
there we're very excited to do our first
ever completely remote meetup is not
actually our first ever remote get up
one time maybe ten years ago we did have
a meet-up when the bulk of the people
were all physically in New York I
believe with the AOL offices and we had
someone remoting in I want to say
Australia but I could be making that up
I know someone actually had to do a
video of one of the presenters actually
did a via video and this was 10 years
ago so it was very exciting for us I'll
give everyone just a little bit more
time then we'll get going just a little
bit
everyone's having a wonderful wonderful
quarantine and making the most of it
hopefully everyone's doing well and it's
healthy and their families are all in
good situations and I hope those of you
kids are surviving and getting through
it and those out are writing a great are
package and hope everyone's just doing
the best they can during these times
okay yes so some people is just on the
queue a thank you for letting us know I
think about the password we made a
last-minute decision because realized we
realized that some people are having
trouble getting the password we turn off
the password because it's in webinar
mode so sorry everyone for that rush but
since it's in webinar mode no one should
be able to show any video or make any
audio unless we turn it on for them so
we felt safe for this instance removing
the password at the last minute
hopefully there won't be any issues and
next month we'll see how we'll do it
then we might not even need to have a
password in the first place so thank you
for pointing that out of week all right
some seems like we have a the number of
joining us stabilized so first up
everyone welcome to the April 2020
Meetup hope everyone's here's a ready to
learn a lot about are a lot about
coronavirus we have a expert in both of
those leading us today so first thing we
always start up the meet up with who's
hiring and since we are in webinar mode
we can't have everyone raise their hand
and say who's hiring so if you could all
go to the slack team that we have for
new your effort and why heck are there
is a job postings channel so if you need
to find that I will post in the chat
here and my hacker org is the meetups
website and if you go there you'll see
there's a page called slack if you're on
mobile you might need to scroll to find
it there's a slack page and then there's
a link for that I'm not actually could
you post the link directly to slack from
the page they'll probably be easier and
if everyone would like to join the slack
team the
there is a new channel for the meetup
tonight Amata what's the name of the
channel he created April 20 April 20 -
Meetup that is the name of the slack
channel for today if anyone wants to
jump in there and chat I figure that's
probably better place in the random
channel or the general Channel but if
you're on there you want to post a job
if you're hiring there is a job postings
channel going to job postings post your
job if you have a link post a link for
it say who the job it where the jobs at
who is for who you're looking for and
hopefully you'll get some good responses
on that so again that's in the NY hack
our slack there is a jobs Channel and
just a reminder
Amada created the April 20 Meetup
channel so go there and chat away about
the meetup about tonight's Meetup we
will be looking for questions hello
Steven thank you for joining from Boston
so if you have questions you can ask
them in either the meetup Channel or
here in the QA whatever you're more
comfortable with and we will go through
them and try to push them towards know'm
at the end of his talk so you know save
your questions toward the end and we
will go through them and ask them of
them ask those questions to know them if
you're interested in getting more
involved with kovat efforts there's also
a kovat 19 channel where a number of
people including Noam and Amanda and I
think Romney is in there these are all
first names I understand but in there
you'll find resources for going and
trying to help people with kovat I just
rose my video turned off sorry about
that folks
so if you look on the slack there is a
kovat 19 channel and in there you'll be
able to share information about Cova
different things you want to do
different tools you're using or
questions you have if you just want to
ask questions because you don't
understand we have a few people who are
experts in coronavirus in there namely
Amanda Noam and Romney I'm sure others
there was a three I know who can help
answer your questions about Kovan in
general about our inchoate normally at
this point of my announcements I say
there's a pizza pole and we asked
questions about pizza and so
unfortunately we can't all be together
but I did make sure
go out and get some pizza you can see it
is exhibiting good cheese lock the
cheese is not sliding off it's a little
not charred too much on the backside so
that's not great but not a lot of tips
add just a little which is what you want
so hope everyone has their own slice of
pizza and is enjoying their meal as Nome
speaks I'm sorry we can't all be
together but this is the best we can do
in these times and hopefully everyone
can enjoy meetup in a comfort
enjoy the meetup and their pizza in the
comfort of their home ordinarily we like
to go to the bar afterwards
unfortunately we all can't go to the bar
so everyone could hang on the slack
channel and talk virtually or if there's
a real demand we maybe could spin up
another zoom
maybe it'll see if it's in our
capabilities everyone grab a beverage
alcoholic non-alcoholic of their choice
and hang out if they would like to next
month's meetup but I we think we settled
on a date I just need to confirm with a
speaker is this gentleman Rami and I
keep mentioning he built the coronavirus
package in our amongst some other
resources so we're assuming we'll be
remote again next month and we will do
another remote meetup and Romney will
have another talk about coronavirus
because I have a feeling people will
still be interested in it in May so
please everyone please look out for the
announcement in the next few days for
the next Meetup
there is a Stan workshop this week
Wednesday through Friday
it's all remote I'm gonna be doing it
through zoom with passwords and webinar
mode and all that if anyone still wants
to sign up you can still sign up today I
think they're closing registrations
today just to make well it just Excel a
bit easier but that will be started by
the drop my phone that will be this week
Jona gabourey rapture and Gucci and then
bales will be leading it and Andrew
Gelman will be passing by to help out
and I'll just be a great time so our
annual stand workshop a great way to
learn about Stan and Beijing data
analysis you can find more information
at and waiheke org I'm sure a lot of you
are interested in the New York our
conference this year supposed to be our
sixth annual our conference right now it
is scheduled for June 11th through 13th
we are deciding later this month if we
have to postpone it to later in the year
or if we have to go all
virtual so check that out at our stats
AI and we can figure out more there we
will post more information our test at
AI over the next few weeks if we decide
to reschedule or go virtual or even if
we're lucky go as planned though we'll
see how that goes we'll follow
governmental advice I see someone's
asking a question about the slack link
maybe not working so you might want you
might want that might be the old link so
if you go to NY hacker org slash slack
that HTML and click the link on that
page then that should take you to the
fresh link in the model we'll try to
grow grab that and paste it we have to
renew the link recently so hopefully the
one she just put up there will work this
time if that that's app dot slack let me
sorry folks let me just go try that I
don't think that's the right one let me
go grab the link that's up there and
people could tell us if it works because
that looks different than this one
try the one that just says join slack
comm and see if that works for you folks
hopefully that'll be a hopefully I'll
fix this so I mentioned nyr we also have
Washington DC our that's scheduled for
November so as of right now that's going
ahead as scheduled and we'll see what
happens at the virus so that again needs
to be rescheduled or go virtual or
whatever maybe so of all that I hope
every members post your jobs on the the
NY hack our slack channel for job
postings chat about today's meetup in
the April 20 meetup Channel enjoy your
pizza at home if you can and think about
the Stan workshop this week and next
month again
Rami will be giving a talk about
coronavirus most likely remote we are
pretty certain it's gonna be a remote
meetup well especially since he's from
California so it's definitely gonna be
remote meetup even if we can go home
person at that point so with that I
would like to introduce our speaker he
spoken a few times at the Meetup
he works for an organization called eco
health alliance which specializes in the
study of emerging viruses and in
particular nome knows quite a bit about
corona virus and you'll see on the
meetup page is a picture of him holding
it's a form of a road it might be a
penguin I'll let him tell you what that
picture is romelo a penguin in a rural
part of China does he study this so I
couldn't think of anyone better to give
a talk about coronavirus NR than Nome
and addition to one the normal toss he
gives about gams and docker images I've
heard this is perfect for him
so everyone please welcome no I'm Ross
thank you very much Jared and thank you
all for coming today we have over 200
people this is way bigger than a typical
eat up that we have for New York are
Iraq mind a lot about what to talk about
for this Meetup we actually hatched the
idea originally back in it was
mid-january Jared said hey do you want
to give a talk in the spring and I said
you know I've talked about workflow and
I could talk about docker and I could
talk about certain types of models but
you know there's this thing happening in
China that's in the news that people
might be interested in I actually can
talk about the substantive research that
I do and Jared said well well I hope
it's still in you know newsworthy in
April and unfortunately it is and I've
read my mind a bit about what to talk
about for this cuz you know this is our
meet up many of you aren't part of the
regular meetup group that we have but
the New York our community is a tight
one and we have a lot of fun and it's a
very somber topic these days for those
of us everywhere in the world this is
profoundly affected just you know our
our lives for those of us especially in
the hot spots it's been a scary time and
a somber time you know and you know
there's a lot of suffering out out there
because of this and I thought well what
what can I talk about what do people
want to hear and so I thought this is
still our you know arming up this is
still our meetup of people who are
interested in models and statistics and
problems and interesting data and I'm
not so much going to try to keep it
light-hearted
try to you know spark and save some
curiosity very much on the you know on
the modeling side to talk about how and
where we use models um a bit about
myself as Jared said I work for a
nonprofit called eco health alliance
that's based in New York and works at
the intersection of wildlife
conservation and human health so we very
much focus on emerging infectious
diseases I'm a disease ecologist and
what that means is it's like disease
ecologist is - epidemiologist as
veterinarian is - doctor so I study the
circulation and emergence and dynamics
of diseases predominantly in wildlife
and how they emerge into humans and so
it's very much the same set of tools
that infectious disease epidemiologists
use and for those of us who work in the
space where those things interact we
work very closely together I also work
for an organization called our open side
which is a developer collective to
support technical and community
infrastructure for our to support open
reproducible science we like to say that
we build communities as much as we build
packages are open SCI is you know is an
open volunteer organization that helps
support scientists do their work and get
access to open data and create open data
so what I thought I'd talk about today
is how do models and how does software
help us understand emerging diseases
like like kovat 19 like other diseases
like SARS and Ebola and like I said what
I wanted to do was focus not just on
coronavirus but sort of say people's
curiosity and pique their interest into
the types of models that we use to
understand things so many people here
are data scientists of various sorts
they have
workflows and tools that they use and
what I wanted to pose was several
scientific questions that I and other
disease ecologists and epidemiologists
work on and with those scientific
questions ask well what are we trying to
find out what models do we use to help
answer those questions and then what
tools do we use for those models because
maybe some of you will be able to pick
up those tools and take them and use
them in your work be it kovat or disease
or health-related or not but maybe some
of you will learn about the methods used
in those tools and be able to apply them
to other things and hopefully it'll help
you all understand something about the
you know the news and the research and
everything that comes out that starts
talking about models of infection
disease there's you know it's a high
point in the culture for infectious
disease modeling things are in the news
that have really rarely been in the news
before and we're inundated with a lot of
information and being able to look at
that and critique it and think about
what those models actually are so that
you can compare them to the other types
of models that you may be using in your
own work and apply your own data science
and statistical backgrounds to
understanding them is something that I
hope you get out of this talk as well so
I'm going to speak about three questions
and then afterwards I'm going to talk a
little bit about the types of things
that people who are on this webinar are
part of the meet up or house where can
do to apply their skills to problems
related to coronavirus so I'm gonna talk
about three types of scientific
questions that we use models to answer
the first one is how do we trace the
source of a disease when we discover new
pathogens new viruses how do we figure
out where they come from the second
question is where are the sources of new
diseases future diseases how do we
understand where risk is and what to
focus on and
to do surveillance and monitoring to
understand the potential for future
outbreaks and then I'm going to talk a
little bit about how we understand how
diseases spread in populations how do
academic scro what stops them what can
be used to forecast the future and for
each of these I'm going to talk a little
bit about what the problem is
what the nature of the data and the
models are we used to solve and then go
a bit into the our packages we use for
those so the first of these is how can
we trace the source of a disease the
picture I'm showing in this slide is in
a cave in Yunnan Province that is full
of horseshoe bats and a couple of people
from my organization there who work in
China sampling bats to deter to discover
the viruses that live in them
many of you have proudly heard in the
news that covin 19 which is caused by
the corona virus now called SARS CoV 2
has its origins or is derived from or
has evolved from bats and how do we know
that and how do we learn that and how to
use data and models to determine that
well it starts with the data first a lot
of data has to be collected in order to
compare things to that virus and that
happens via people doing the type of
work like they're doing in this picture
which is sampling both wildlife and
people who work with or near or live
near wildlife sampling things like blood
samples or saliva samples or fecal
samples and doing testing to determine
what viruses are out there what viruses
are circulating in the general
population of different types of animals
or maybe occasionally spilling over into
humans that potentially could cause
outbreaks and what that does is that
creates a bank of data against which new
viruses can be compared to so let's
think about the type of data one has
when you have a new virus and you need
to compare it
try to understand its source so this is
the type of data that one is working
with when one's trying to understand the
origin of viruses its genetic data so
genetic data comes from genetic testing
and sequencing and when one has a sample
from from a wildlife or human you can
identify the viruses in them collect the
DNA or the RNA in those viruses and use
molecular processes to sequence those
and you get a sequence of letters or
nucleotides that make up the DNA or RNA
sequences of these viruses and they look
like this it's a string a string of
letters ATG and see if it's R and if
it's RNA there's a there's a un there as
a replacement which is a different
different molecule but this is the
genetic sequence of viruses and this is
the type of data one is working in one
height have a new virus and you might
want to compare it to that Bank of other
viruses that have been collected by
wildlife researchers and biologists over
years and decades and banking them in
these genetic data archives one note is
that the sequences themselves are models
they're not just data like everything
the data collection process is noisy and
the chemical processes that one uses to
extract these RNA and then try to align
segments of them together and determine
how much noise there is over eating them
over and over again introduce errors so
these sequences themselves are sort of
consensus models of doing that
sequencing over and over again but it is
something that's standardized enough and
we understand those models well enough
that you can have pretty reliable
consensus sequence sequencing although
there are certainly cases where that
type of error is important as well so if
you're a data scientist and not
necessarily someone who worked in virus
or genetics and you want to understand
the relationships between say this new
viruses sequences and these genetic
sequences from a series of other virus
that might have been collected and you
want to understand which ones are closer
to each other you might use something
like some sort of clustering algorithm
approach you might use something say
like string distance or you can use the
string dist package and use any number
of met any number of functions that
measure the difference in overall
substitutions between two strings and
you could come up with some sort of
relationship of the difference between
different genetic sequences and this is
exactly sort of one of the approaches
one can use in order to compare genetic
sequences and in the genetic world a
common algorithm is a code that's a
clustering algorithm used for this is
what's called generating a median
joining Network so the median joining
network is the medium best consensus
Network joined by just a straightforward
difference clustering algorithm and the
picture I'm showing here is one of these
median joining networks that compares
viruses that were collected from
individuals who had SAR Co v2 with
viruses there were an any number of
species of bats in southeast China South
South and Southeast China that have
other coronaviruses and so this median
joining Network gives you an idea of
their relationships amongst those
viruses and this is sort of a straight
forward clustering algorithm that's used
as sort of a first pass of understanding
relationships amongst genetic sequences
it's a fast sort of fast quick and dirty
way of doing this that gives you an
understanding of the topology of a
network like this that you know requires
very few resources and lets you
understand how to pursue your data
analysis analysis from then on so you
can have this clustering approach but
when you really want to look more
carefully at the early
ships amongst genetic sequences you want
to introduce more knowledge into the
process this is sort of a naive
clustering approach but we know there's
a lot of biology and process and
non-linearity in how genetic sequences
are relate to each other because they're
not just sequences of strings and
differences they're the result of
evolution and the evolution process is
directed and makes certain patterns
appear in genetic sequences that one has
to account for so usually when you see
how organisms are related to each other
you don't see it by this sort of
undirected network approach but instead
you see something that generates
something called a phylogeny or a
phylogenetic tree and that's the kind of
thing one uses in order to understand
the relationship of viruses or other
organisms to other organisms that might
have common ancestors that they evolved
from so this figure that I'm showing on
this slide is from paper that
characterized the SARS CoV 2 virus which
causes the Cova 19 disease that was
published just a couple months ago in
February really rapidly really fast
turnaround in understanding a new virus
like this and what they did here is they
generated this phylogenetic tree which
is another network representation of
this genetic information the one that
explicitly includes the evolutionary
structure of those relationships so in
red we have in the bottom red the bat
virus that was collected in southern
China several years ago and then several
other of our samples of the what at the
time was just novel coronavirus and now
as SAR Co V 2 and by explicitly using
sort of evolution as part of the
structure of one's model you can create
these phylogeny
so the phylogeny itself this tree
it's not data the tree itself is a model
in this case you make what's called a
maximum likelihood tree that uses a
maximum likelihood approach much like
one dozen you know regression models and
trees like this also have error and
uncertainty and so one often uses a
bootstrap approach in developing trees
like this if you can see the branches of
these trees have little numbers on them
and that's the fraction of the the
percentage of the bootstrap that that's
the percentage of the bootstrap samples
that support that's topology so there
can be uncertainty in these trees and if
you're looking at something like this
you see it in a paper you see it in the
news you see someone recreate it one of
the important things is to understand
the nature of the uncertainty in that
topology because the tree is not an
absolute thing any more than a
regression line is it's a model that's
created out of data and when one's
building things like these phylogenetic
trees you have a whole lot of different
approaches and a lot of considerations
and you have many of the same challenges
that one has when doing other
identifying other model building other
machine learning so one might take a
clustering a nonparametric approach that
just you know links things together you
can do this maximum likelihood and
bootstrapping approach in which you try
to find this tree that best represents
the evolutionary process and you can go
all the way to Bayesian inference so you
know just like in a regression model you
can do a maximum likelihood and
confidence intervals so you can
represent a whole posterior you can get
a whole posterior of different trees and
you can interrogate that output and
understand that posterior and ask
questions about things they are
uncertain then you're not uncertain and
when you're doing that these trees often
aren't simple because the evolutionary
process is not simple in itself you have
to think a lot about of a lot of a lot
of things like the mutation rate that's
actually going on
in the the genes saying that mutation
rate might change in time or it might
change along different parts of the
sequence because different genes have
different mutation rates perhaps because
some of them represent some of them
represents something which is under
evolutionary selection and some of them
may not also while in mutation you just
think of like individual genes or
individual proteins changing bit by bit
over time sometimes you have other
things like recombination which
reshuffles the genetic material and
really would throw a wrench into your
phylogenetic tree process if you
couldn't explicitly account for it
somehow so just like when you're doing
the regression model you have to start
maybe thinking about Oh perhaps there's
time or space and autocorrelation has to
be included or maybe this component
should be a random vector or fixed
effect these types of considerations go
into the process of generating
phylogenetic tree models and you have to
tweak them and identify the right
sources of heterogeneity that you need
to explicitly include in the model maybe
because you need to correct for it and
you're trying to control or maybe
because it's the thing you're most
interested in because understanding like
those variation in mutation rates helps
you for instance understand if parts of
the genetic sequence are evolving so
just like how and are there 100 packages
for every type of type of your question
there's a whole world of phylogenetic
modeling software for making these trees
and for taking different approaches so
there are a couple called there's re XML
and IQ tree and those are maximum
likelihood approaches the first one is a
rapid algorithm for ML and then there
are a couple of software packages that
are for Bayesian evolutionary analysis
for generating all those posteriors of
trees much like a lot of other software
in are these things often have to be
coding in low level languages like C in
order to get the performance you need
but you know that doesn't stop our users
if there is a useful piece of software
out there and our user will write a
package in order to connect to it and
use it and create bindings to use things
so there are things like the IPPS
package that is the interface to
phylogenetic software or the Harriet R
for IQ tree and there's a fantastic
package that I like to promote called
Beauty our four beasts one nice thing
about that is it's an are open SCI
peer-reviewed whole suite of packages
for people who use that type of 12 tools
so like some of these other ones it's
been validated for peer for through a
peer review process not just of the
approach but the code and that's one of
the things that are up inside does that
help scientists and so you get this
whole world of software and it's sort of
like probably parallel to the things
you're used to using for regression or
Bayesian analysis and when you see trees
that represent the relationship between
viruses or dinosaurs or anything like
that you can understand that you have
the same type of processes going on in
trying to develop those and do inference
on those and use those to understand the
nature of the evolution and the Origin
of Species
there's a one application of this
relating to Cova that it really like to
highlight which is a website called next
strand org next strain was originally
created to track flu-related evolution
and has been used to track all sorts of
viral outbreaks worldwide and is a
tremendous effort out of the university
of washington but with a global team and
lots of participants to continually
track the sequences of new viruses as
they are collected worldwide and there
are more than 10,000 samples I think of
kovat virus genes that have been posted
to a public site called GIS aid and that
neck strain has used to create this mass
tree
and this really helps understand not
just the origin of say the virus to its
wildlife hosts but the origin of
clusters of viruses and infections so
you can understand something about how
the disease spreads in time and space
because one can track you know clusters
or strains or what they call clades of
the virus to the set of viruses that
they were imported from and that helps
researchers understand movement in time
and space so if you go to next rainn.org
you get these fantastic interactive
trees that are linked with maps and they
show how this sequence had an ancestor
related to another sequence for instance
it was something that was used at the
first outbreak in Seattle or outside
Seattle in Washington to show that there
was community transmission because
different sequences were clearly related
to each other and not being imported
from separate places so one could
distinguish community transmission from
new imports by looking at the
phylogenetic trees of those genetic
sequences one of the things we've
learned in New York is that many of the
early cases originated from Europe and
we understand that stood that from
comparison comparing European sequences
to the sequences from early cases in New
York and there were lots of those
sequences relative to say sequences from
Asia so this is something that is
interesting but is also an important
epidemiological tool to understanding
and reconstructing the spread of an
outbreak so
jump to a different question here which
is what are the sources of future
diseases so I once it again
you know return to this photo about of
the collection of viruses from bats in
this cave in China because it's not
coincidence that people were there
researching it was part of a large-scale
project to collect viruses and
understand the distribution of viruses
globally and the potential for outbreaks
this one was under a project called
predict that was run by the State
Department but it's been a big
scientific enterprise across many
institutions and many grants and over
many many many years sort of a whole
field devoted to understanding where are
their viruses and other pathogens in
animals that could spill over into
humans what is the probability that it's
going to what are the locations where it
might be likely to happen and what are
the animal species that might Harbor
those viruses and so this isn't as much
a genetic Enterprise as understanding
thing the distribution of things in time
and space and understanding and
characterizing a risk and so we have a
different type of data we might be
working with not so much the genetic
sequences but we often have things like
pairwise associations so this is just a
data table I pulled a right out of a
project a project of mine where we have
a big list of viruses and their
associations with the types of animals
that been found to harbor them and the
types of tests that have been used to
collect that and this is data that has
been collected from decades and decades
and decades of research that's
representing the literature are
harvested from all that literature and
aggregated to say what do we know about
which viruses are in what animals and
what can we use to use to take that data
and make pretty
actions about where viruses might be in
the future so this is one type of data
one might have when trying to do this
sort of large-scale race type analysis
another type of data one might have is
spatial so one might have an association
of a virus with a species that is hosted
but then you have to know where those
viruses are and where those species are
so you might have records that look like
this if there is a thing called the
global biodiversity information facility
it's a huge global consensus database of
records of where scientists have
recorded the existence and the habitats
of various species so rhino Lofa
saphenous is at the intermediate
horseshoe bat it's the one that the
closest related sequence to coronavirus
was found in in yunnan in china and this
is a map of records of places where it's
been observed so you can have this
geospatial data on a point data saying
here's a place where the species has
been seen here is a place where this
species has been seen here is a place
where this species has been seen and you
understand data like this has its own
problems and challenges for working with
and you're probably familiar with a
bunch of these because it's a very
common set of problems one has in a
regression or supervised learning of
various sorts so one of the big problems
we tend to have with this is sparse data
unlike you know web traffic or credit
card clicks or social media data um it's
very expensive to collect a single data
point often for this kind of thing is
like to say a single row of data for me
represents someone in the woods all
night with the net to catch a rodent
draw its blood swipe its butthole with a
q-tip and let it go and the fact that
that happens thousands and thousands of
times is pretty amazing but you realize
it's a very very small sample of what's
actually out there
and we know that sampling is highly
biased there are places that scientists
work more there are places that have
been researched less there are species
that there's been more effort on if
you're trying to draw lots of data out
of the scientific record or out of the
collective databases you know it's going
to be biased in different ways there are
species that have been preferentially
looked at for various reasons maybe they
are of interest for reasons not related
to disease we know that collection
happens more aggressively near
population centers that's where people
observe things you need an observer in
order to find an animal you have all
sorts of correlation issues you know you
have Geographic autocorrelation and
correlation between types of species
that phylogenetic relationship and then
you know these type of predictions
involve non-linearity and interactions
and you have all of the challenge of
dealing with prediction versus inference
trade-off so you're trying to figure out
where the viruses of the animals are are
you trying to make predictions out of
that for when you go back and do
sampling in the future or are you trying
to make a trade-off so you can
understand some mechanism which piece of
you know what type of trait of an animal
is most predictive or indicates the
reason the reason why an animal might
have a virus in them you want to
understand that and for that reason all
of these considerations one throws a
tool set that people who are general
data scientists would probably be very
familiar with at these types of problems
there are general linear models and
generalized additive models which are
more on the inference size you can have
mechanistic models that very much
explicitly model the type of habitat or
the relationship between a host and a
host and its pathogen one can use that
machine learning approach not just math
maximum likelihood or machine learning
approaches sometimes you just interested
in prediction and so you can use
nonparametric blackbox approaches to try
to identify things in space or you might
want to sort of use Bayesian approaches
and be able to
once again interrogate a posterior and
do full Bayesian inference and all of
these considerations and these
approaches are used for trying to do
this general type of prediction so I'm
going to sort of give you a gallery of
some of these so this is the map from
the paper put out by Eko Health Alliance
a few years ago about which is sort of
considered a risk map for places that
may potentially have new viruses
emerging and it builds off a data set of
historical new emergencies of viruses
into the human population from wildlife
and then tries to use that data for a
prediction so this uses a boosted tree
approach the our package is involved
building it or the dismal package which
is a boosted tree approach specific to
species distributions but also
xg-- boost which is a very general
boosted regression tree approach and the
idea was to use a bunch of information
about a location to understand whether
it's a place that would be more or less
at risk to having a new zone otic
disease spillover occur there so you can
understand that that's a regression
problem or a supervised learning problem
and you have all of the challenges of
say where there has been more or less
surveillance there are places where
people have looked a lot and people have
looked a little so this was in a time
where we created a variable based on all
of the locations that people have
mentioned in the published literature
related to disease we took a natural
language approach try to identify places
that people studied more and studied
less and that highly biased sampling we
tried to address by then making a
spatial layer that modified our model
based on the degree of sampling and the
degree of you know virus observation
effort there had been over the decades
in which these emergency
occur and then one wants to do not just
potentially have predictions but
understand what's driving those
predictions and so for that one might
use partial dependence plots which is a
common way of interrogating a machine
learning model and so these are partial
dependence plots of this boosted
regression tree but we wanted to
understand uncertainty in them so we
created a bootstrapping approach that
bootstrapped
not just the data randomly but the data
according to that Geographic bias and
that helped us understand the
uncertainty around these partial effects
and which variables made something a
place more or less likely to be a place
where a new virus emerged out into the
human population so some of the
variables that were important for this
are the mammal biodiversity the number
of species that are out there that can
potentially harbor viruses there are
several measures that are important
related to tree cover so general
forested areas where people are
encountering those animals more more
likely but it was also important that
there were places where those forested
areas run up against urban areas and
highly settled areas or even areas where
there was land-use change happening
people were clearing pasture all those
things made it more likely that a place
would have an emerging disease occur
over the course of decades as this goes
back to the 1940s so that's you know one
approach we have looking at viruses and
the geographic risk another thing that
we're interested in looking at is what
species are the ones that are hosts to
different viruses so in addition to
where do viruses emerge you want to ask
the question and make the prediction
well what types of species are more
likely to be host to a virus that could
eventually reach the human population
once again a big regression or
supervised learning problem those of you
who have
seen me talk before at the Meetup might
know that sort of my favorite tool for
this kind of thing is a game or a
generalized additive model which is a
nice sort of compromise between the more
elaborate machine learning approaches
but also the more interpretable
generalized linear model approaches
these are much like generalized linear
models but allow for nonlinear effects
and let you sort of choose how they
interact rather than automatically
creating lots of crosses like in in
boosted trees so once again we had that
problem of bias certain species are more
heavily studied than others and so we
once again looked at well let's
introduce a variable as to how many
studies have been done on each species
and use that as a measure of effort and
that's the biggest predictor of whether
you find a virus in something but one
can also one also finds effects of
slightly bigger animals are more likely
to have viruses in them ones that have
big ranges ones that have big ranges
that overlap with other types of animals
so there's the potential for interaction
between different species and we were
able to look at different categories of
animals different big taxonomic groups
so for instance one thing that we find
is that bats as a group while there's a
small effect once you account for all of
the other biases and everything else to
put in the model overall are more likely
to host some of these viruses than
others and that's something that's been
seen in a lot of studies though there
was a lot of speculation as to why that
might be and whether that has to do with
sampling approaches or potentially has a
lot to do with the physiology of the
animals also that last group on the
right is you know we also have primates
and rodents and other ones that are
potentially more hosts of more viruses
that can spill over into humans so this
uses that type of regression approach a
colleague of mine Greg Albury who might
be on here has used this for another
interesting
approach of not just asking well which
viruses spill from wildlife into humans
but from one wildlife species into
another which viruses do we find in
multiple groups and given that we find a
virus say in a bat species what other
species what we find it in because
they're likely to share and so we also
used this generalized additive modeling
approach because of sort of the ability
to build these structured models with it
and found this combined relationship
between the amount of space that species
habitat ranges overlap with each other
and as well as their genetic
relationship with each other
combined to help you predict a lot of
the probability the virus can jump from
one species to another species and with
that you can sort of create this
response service and ask if you find a
virus in one type of organism what other
types of organisms might it be in and
maybe those aren't interesting ones to
go after for surveillance in order to
understand in order to potentially look
for new potential spill overs and other
animals that could potentially have
viruses that spill over into people and
this work has also sort of extended into
sort of a whole other sort of
combination of models where some work
led by a great researcher down at
Georgetown Colin Carlson who may be here
as well has taken that along with these
binary classification models for where
species live in order to understand how
climate change might change the
distribution of viruses in the world so
one can create a model to understand
where animal species live based on the
climate they prefer certain temperatures
that prefer certain seasonality is they
also prefer certain types of habitats
and one can create a binary
classification or regression model with
something like GLM net that's what was
used it was used here with a lot of
other bells and whistles
- and then take that and combine that
with a model of well what predicts what
viruses are in them and what viruses are
shared and then you can make projections
or forecasts because you have a
relationship between climate and habitat
as well as animals and viruses and then
you ask how are the viruses going to
move with their hosts as hosts move over
time with climate change as the climate
in places change and the preferred
habitat change so all of these models
that I look at that sort of I've just
talked about things that help us
understand essentially the US in space
and time where do we see viruses and
what's these do we see them in and where
we see those species those are very much
these are aggression machine learning
approaches that may be familiar to you
from all sorts of other data science
work you do and we encounter both
problems that everyone encounters about
data quality and sparsity and then we
have these things that are really unique
to the problem of hosts and viruses and
the way people observe them and the way
that data is collected so I'm going to
turn to a third set a very different set
of models now for the last section which
is talk about how diseases actually
spread in the population the data which
I'll talk about in this is something
that you probably have all become quite
familiar with following in the news the
data that we look at that we try to
understand things from and predict
things from our time series data and
time series data of things like the
observation of new infections new tests
individuals new hospitalized individuals
people who died from a disease and we've
all been following with sort of you know
you know great grim attention that for
kovat over the past couple of months
what I'm showing here is a plot I
believe of daily new of new cases from
the coronavirus dashboard at John
Hopkins University this coronavirus gh
unit edu is a great resource for both
visualization as well as the raw data of
cases kovat that John Hopkins has
developed and this is the type of data
one is dealing with and it can have all
sorts of challenges as well so one gets
time series data of these things but
there's all sorts of challenges with
observation and the quality of the data
for instance we know in many places
there's not a you know consistent
testing approach so who is tested is
might be that not be the whole
population or a random sample of the
population it gives you a different
understanding of gives you a different
understanding of how many cases they're
actually out there when hospitals report
deaths or nursing home reports deaths
sometimes it takes them a few days to
report things sometimes it's slower to
report things on busier days or over the
weekends you get spikes on Monday so you
have all of these data quality
challenges and difficulties
interpretation of these and then you
want to use this data to understand the
progression of the disease to maybe make
forecasts about the disease to try to
take planning approaches to the disease
so you have a lot of considerations in
terms of what you're of what you're
doing so maybe you're trying to forecast
the future you're trying to do some sort
of time series in order to understand
the capacity that's need for healthcare
or maybe you're not actually trying to
forecast but you're trying to scenario
plan because there's a lot of potential
outcomes and a lot of different policy
approaches the one might take and you
want to look at what the potential
changes in the future might be if you
look at those different scenarios which
may or may not be certain futures you
have the challenge that you're basically
entirely doing out-of-sample predictions
you know we are sort of entering a new
dynamic space that none of us has
encountered before when you're making a
prediction it's not a prediction that's
trained off of lots of similar outbreak
there have been no similar outbreaks
perhaps you could say 1918 was a similar
outbreak but it was of a very different
virus from a different very different
family lots of things were different
there are a lot of types of uncertainty
that you might want to deal with or not
want to deal with so there's uncertainty
in the parameters that you're putting
into models that might be measured from
the literature there's uncertainty as to
what the quality of the data is and then
often that data is partial so you have
all those considerations and then
similarly you have a bunch of different
approaches you might take to building a
model of disease over time so one can
take a mechanistic approach that very
much follows sort of principles of
disease dynamics and epidemiology one
can take a phenomenological approach
which says well let's fit based on sort
of previous events and no matter sort of
what drove that event we're just going
to sort of do a data-driven approach one
might think of things in a deterministic
way you know a leads to B and be
primarily interested in you know the
average effect which is not that noisy
or you might be interested in the noise
and want to pursue the things that have
to do with stochasticity and chance and
your probability distributions and so
there's a lot of different models one
might pick and different approaches one
might take to what you're trying to do
here forecasting or planning or trying
to make some statistical inference about
the how the disease is working over time
so one type of model which has gotten a
lot of attention and has been used a lot
both historically epidemiologically and
very much now in the code 19 outbreak is
what's known as the SI r model or the
susceptible infected recovered model
which is a very classic very old
approach to modeling infectious diseases
that has yielded no enormous insights
and it's a very simple approach that can
be made very very complex and I'm going
to show an example of it that comes from
a great shiny app that you can go and
look at created by Allison Hill
at Harvard public health and she put
together a shiny app that demonstrates
use of this model that's meant for sort
of scenario planning so these types of
models break up the population into
different groups of individuals those
that are susceptible to disease but
haven't gotten it those that are exposed
but Ness having this they've been
infected those have been infected and
then those could be any number of
subclasses those who have a severe case
of the disease those that have a mild
case of the disease those that have a
case of the disease they don't even know
is the disease because they don't have
symptoms and then those both those
individuals after they recover and some
of those individuals when they die and
each of those compartments is
represented by a differential equation
which is a rate equation that says how
this group of people grows or shrinks
depending on what's going on in all the
other groups of people or based on other
external forcing factors so that's all
put together and represent it as a set
of differential equations which is what
I'm showing on the left and when you use
a differential equation solver in R or
elsewhere to solve those questions you
get a simulation of what happens with
those diseases going forward so at
Allison site you can do those types of
simulations which predict how many
people will be infected how many cases
we'll have although I'll be careful to
say it's not necessarily a prediction so
many of these models are not fit
directly to data but rather are highly
dependent on parameters that might be
measured elsewhere or are choices that
one makes you know you could you know
it's very important that things like
this often are represented with these
sliders next to them which is why they
make great applications of things like
shiny apps because there are values that
we may or may not have good numbers for
and you can look at the scenario and
they're high in the scenario when
they're low and say well you know what
if we can get 10% of people who get the
infection to self isolate or what if we
can get
90% how does that change the dynamics of
this system as representing these
equations you know what happens if we
totally reduce their infection arey when
they're in the hospital or we're not
able to at all
all of those sliders some of which
represents things that are uncertainty
and some of which represent things that
our choices have huge effects on what
the outcomes of these models are and so
they're often more about understand
during the range of possible outcomes
and the relationship between those
inputs and the outputs as doing
forecasting and prediction and that's
one of the reasons models are very
different that and you hear about very
different results is that the
assumptions going into them are
different because they can often
represent a different policy scenarios
or behavior scenarios now the model
that's shown here and the one in Allison
showed is a deterministic model but
that's not necessarily what happens in
the real world there's a lot of chance
in the real world and so often what
wants to do is to do is represent such
models using stochastic processes so
much like one can say simulate from a
linear regression using random sampling
to represent the noise a stochastic
process rather than simulating and then
adding noise has noise built into the
simulation and built into the process so
given a set of assumptions or parameters
or at the beginning you can have a very
different set of outcomes because of
those stochastic processes and so this
site another really useful shiny app
kovin measures github Daioh is put
together by a group in Stanford out of a
lab a woman Erin Mordecai that similarly
lets you sort of play with different
intervention intervention measures to
understand what would happen in the case
of different scenarios but one of the
things that can show you is the variance
in those scenarios so rather than just
using differential equations to solve it
uses stochastic equations which result
in
these many different possible outcomes
even given the same inputs and that's
important because the real world is
noisy and random and understanding the
range of possibilities is just as
important as understanding understanding
the average outcome one plug I'll give
for if you're interested in this space
is an R package called Odin so these
differential equations on one hand you
can have very small number of them and
have a very simple model but things get
very complex when one starts thinking
about space so lots of different
populations interacting from different
places or over a network or things like
demographics you have lots of different
people at different ages each of which
represents a group and that can become
very calm very complex and
computationally intense now the best
solvers are really available in our in a
package called de salt and they're super
fast because they're not written in are
they're written in Fortran they go back
to the 1970s and they've been maintained
as sort of top-of-the-line solvers ever
since um but that means you have to
write code and C or Fortran to make it
run fast this oden package which is put
together by a guy named grits Fitch John
who is at Imperial College actually part
of that group that produced some of the
famous early forecasts for Co vid has
created a package that lets you write
differential equations in R and then it
compiles that our codes to C so it can
run a really fast
so it's kind of like a domain-specific
language for these types of equations
that you use to predict epidemiological
processes but sort of like deep liar it
has its own language but when it
executes it does everything very quickly
and see so that's a great a great
package rich is also part of our open
side project so this has gotten a lot of
scrutiny and it's something that's been
used a lot for this type of work
now sometimes one is just similar
for parameters but you can also take
that time series data and fit to these
mechanistic models which is not as
commonly done but it's certainly
possible and though it's something
challenging and that's when you rather
than just trying to fit a linear
regression or an exponential curve
actually try to fit a whole dynamic
model of this sort to observe data like
deaths or hospitalizations or testing
understanding that's coming from
uncertain data sources in are there a
lot of options for this there's n LM e
it's sort of the nonlinear fitting
package but also stan has a full-blown
differential equation solver inside it
so you can make models that have those
dynamics and then fit data to it
increasingly the BRMS package with lots
of people who use for Bayesian model
fitting is putting together the
facilities to do this as well and if
this is something you're interested in
there's a there's a neat paper that
shows sort of a comparison of different
packages for doing it by the douche
often been bulker who some of you might
know from creating the LM e for package
that's really widely used as well as a
bunch of others in our one thing that I
really like to use is another variant of
this which is called a partially
observed Markov process so basically
that idea is that we have stochasticity
in our process and incomplete
observation since you have two different
types of uncertainty driving what one
sees in the data and so you sort of have
this process model which is this noisy
random series of events that occur
underneath and then sort of a noisy way
of sampling that data on top of it and
that's the real world we have the
randomness in what happens and
imprecision in what we in how we see it
so there's a great package for looking
at those mechanistic models of that sort
in our as well called pump for partially
observed Markov process and so that will
try to fit mechanistic models with
uncertain parameters to this noisy type
of day
in real life and it's something I've
been using a lot and then parameters
like the transmission rate or how long
the course of the disease lasts can not
only be drawn from other external
sources but be some of them can be fit
directly to the data and Aaron Kings
website has an absolutely fantastic
series of tutorials and approaches to
doing this and it's a really interesting
thing that one can use for
epidemiological research and trying to
fit models data data to understand what
sort of dynamics in the future disease
will have but also potentially lots of
other real world nonlinear processes so
before I wrap up I wanted to talk a
little about things that our users and
data scientists are in the space can do
that help code nineteen there are lots
of things we can all do besides staying
at home besides watching our hands
besides helping educate people and and
doing what you can get from be it via
donating or supporting or helping take
care of each other I know lots of people
who are data focused people who are
quantitative people people sort of see
everything that's out there and I think
they want to apply those skills and
there are ways that people can do that
and I think people who are attending
this and are part of the Meetup likely
want to be able to help contribute in
that way so there are lots of ways and
lots of organizations but I'm going to
talk just a little bit about one called
recon recon is the our epidemics
consortium it's been around for a number
of years and has a focus on developing
tools and training and sort of frontline
deployment for helping epidemiologists
gather and analyze data about frontline
diseases so it's a membership
organization where lots of those members
are epidemiology me ologists trying to
do work on the frontline from
sort of forecasting future to just
collecting and tidying and trying to
report data in as fast and as helpful
away as possible and so we Khan has two
people that write software that collect
information that but then also actually
sort of deploy to the front lines of
epidemics so they'll garden training
workshops but a number of recon members
have gone to West Africa and to Central
Africa to work on the Ebola outbreaks
that have been there to make sure that
the data there is collected well that
it's tidied that it's organized that can
they can write automated reports that
get delivered to policymakers so they
can understand how those go and many
many of the members they are working in
sort of all of the countries that they
are to support this type of work and
develop sort of policy relevance data
and models to medical workers and
frontline policy workers and such as
well they have a really great website of
resources we can learn about those
things and then the core group develops
a lot of our packages that are used by
those epidemiologists so these are ones
that you know take in standard types of
epidemiological data or help you
organize that epidemiological data and
make certain types of forecasts'
forecasts of hospital beds that are
needed trying to understand the current
transmission rate in a place in time so
you can see whether you're doing better
or worse in time in terms of trying to
control the disease I'm trying to
organize information for contact tracing
to go and find individuals who might
have been exposed to disease there's a
whole suite of our packages for people
who do this work and these types of our
packages can use our developers to help
fix bugs to help develop so recently
recon has launched something called the
cogut 19 of and right now is sort of
existence as a github repository but
working with the our consortium it's
going to be built out into more of a
broader interaction forum where people
who are working in covert early and
G can post issues of problems that they
have that they would like support from
our programmers and data scientists and
others to help solve so for instance
sometimes a new source of data comes
online but it's not well organized and
it needs to be scraped and turned it
into a package that you collect that
sometimes an epidemiologist develops a
new tool say a new way of estimating the
value like a new like to project
Hospital better requirements and they've
done the math and they've done the
initial version but they could use help
getting it pushed further along to be
made into a package or made into a shiny
app that people could consume so the
idea is kovat 1904 the support and
people who are experienced data
scientists and our software developers
can pick those up up and help them use
it I posted things to this of you know I
found there's this new data source and
it's going to take a bunch of time to
figure out how to connect to it and pull
it and can someone and can someone set
that up while we're working on other
things that are high priority and a lot
of people have come through and there's
been a really great work sometimes all
that's needed to do is just the
coordination you've put up a request and
somebody else knows oh that thing is
being worked on over there you can
connect so people who are just sort of
on top of things even if you can't
necessarily program and you know every
type of problem that's there can really
contribute
we are hoping with the our consortium to
get someone some dedicated time for
someone to be a community manager to
help connect people because a lot of the
challenge is you know knowing the right
people who have the skills that connect
to cert to certain problems but this is
a place that people can help with so
that's it um thank you very much
it's an honor to be able to speak to
such a large group it's great to speak
about an important topic the the New
York our community and the New York our
meetup has been really important to me
an important part of the community in
this city and a community that you know
continues to pull together to support
each other in a really hard time and
support everyone else in the city and
everyone else dealing with this work so
thank you very much Jared for having me
thank you all for attending and I'd be
happy to answer any questions if you
know him
so I compiled a few of the questions
from people who are asking asking there
so let me pull them up so the first
question on my list is and identifying
the the type of virus have you
researched any cure methods for them
that's not work that I'm doing there is
a lot of there's a lot of work in both
therapeutics and of course vaccines
which is sort of the most important you
know really the most important part of
ultimately bringing an end and end to
the pandemic but one of the things that
actually is important in this is that
sort of early discovery of diversity of
diseases and understanding those
phylogenetic trees and relationships
because a lot of the work that has gone
into developing potentially therapeutic
vaccines has gotten a head start from
other stars like corona viruses that
have been found and have been tested and
people have thought about if something
like this comes along that we can look
at and if there's a new virus that's
related to the current viruses we can
sort of get a head start on the types of
therapies and no it's so there's already
been work going on in understanding
possible cure possible treatments and
possible ways of dealing with corona
viruses generally there's a group down
south carolina's the barrack lab who's
been working very hard on this for a
long time that collaborate with us
because we often find some of the
viruses and they're the ones who try to
understand which ones might the worst
and which ones might you know have some
potential to help us understand future
cures so that's something that's real
to that work though it's not something
that I worked on myself good that was
another question someone had can the
phylogenetic modeling help us find a
cure so thank you for answering that one
another question is can you point to
free datasets that they can use to
explore this well there are a lot I mean
it really is an amazing time with this
so I will when we follow up and post and
maybe after talking I can I can post
some in the slack or the chat but for
instance if you're interested in disease
dynamics and spread and numbers both
that John Hopkins website as well as the
New York Times published for the United
States at least published really regular
numbers in you know the the changes in
cases and deaths and things like that at
a very granular level they've really
been been collect that stuff there's
also if you know I'm sure I'll get the
ire of a lot of population geneticists
of sending a bunch of people to you know
explore genetic data on their own but
the you know genetic data is something
that is super super available because
science it's been so standardized for so
long the format's
it's actually really a field that is
very open easy and that did is published
with so there's a site GIS AI dgs aid
that is an international site where
scientists post the sequences of the
viruses that they get and they collect
that's what that next strain website
builds off of it gets all the sequences
from there that it does that tree
building and then the next strain site
site itself is a great source because it
points you to everything that it
collects and so you can see where the
cases are and where the sequences are
and then some of the things I'll post
them the websites of you know where the
data is of say the host and species
relationship information a lot of that
is published alongside with our papers
and I'll put that in the notes as well
great
another question we had is what type of
model are you using for geospatial data
um well there are lots of different ones
um so if we're looking at say that what
we call the hot spots model which is the
model the risk map but we're in space
viruses are that uses a boosted
regression tree approach I tend to use
because it's my hammer a lot generalized
additive models for geospatial data
because they're very good at
incorporating auto correlative
geospatial effects and if you're
interested in that I actually have an
online course I'll put a link to that
too which has a component on how to fit
those models to geospatial data it is
that built into M GCV yes that's the M
GCV package okay that package is magical
could do just about everything and for
those of you who want to learn more
about that too I posted in the slack
channel links to nomes
video and his slides from when he spoke
about this at the meetup a few years ago
and that's actually one of our top
watched videos of all time so it's a big
hit
another question we have is what package
did you use to produce the partial
dependence plots oh so the partial
dependence plots for for those booster
regression trees that was definitely a
very elaborate and customized thing so
there Gigi plots but they were done by
from scratch and not by me by a great
epidemiologist Allen who is now at a
place called the recurse works at the
recurse Center in New York so he did a
lot of that hot spot modeling work and
is the lead on that paper so that's what
did that um there are a lot of good
packages for that kind of thing I like
something called the Dale X package
which is for machine learning sort of
model explanations that's good for
partial dependence plots when you have a
sort of complex model like that if
you're interested in boosted regression
trees there's a
a new sort of Bayesian package the
Bayesian additive regression trees and
there's a neat package called
Embarcadero because they're Bart's and
Bart's is the the San Francisco transit
where which stops it in barcode arrow
and it by Colin Carlson and it
automatically creates partial dependent
spots for those true based models that
it that it does so great and I am
putting a link right now because you
mentioned Bart's I'm putting this in the
slack Channel
Jennifer Hill gave a talk at the meetup
a couple years ago about one of the
topics she covered was Bart and the BART
pack is just one of the bark packages
was written by Vince Dory who was there
and he should be speaking to meet up at
some point soon let's see
so you discussed about emergence from
unintentional human interaction of
wildlife
what about modeling about intentional
interactions interactions such as
cultivation of wildlife for human use or
consumption yeah I mean that's an
interesting so you know it's a it's a
very common pattern that new diseases
from wildlife actually passed through
domesticated livestock before getting to
humans because domesticated livestock
are often interacting with wildlife sort
of at the edge of their range but
domesticated animals often say in a much
more crowding environment so they're
much more likely to be able to transmit
the disease to each other and sort of
cause an acceleration of of disease
transmission and so that is something
that has definitely been modeled in a
lot of different ways and so one is the
degree to which those livestock are just
like a predictor in like space and time
of emergence but it's often been a more
mechanistic approach so for instance in
Malaysia
there's and also in Bangladesh there's a
disease known as the Nipah virus that is
transmitted from bats but has infected
humans through pigs and so it's because
the wildlife end up dropping like food
scraps and feces and things like that
inst
place where the animals are harbored
that you can get this spillover so it's
a common it's a common pattern and there
are a lot of different ways so there's a
paper we have this which shows how those
Pig dynamics actually are what drive the
disease it just needs to be seeded by
the introduction from wildlife and
you'll be able to post that to the slack
channel later when you're done yeah
that'd be great
another question I see here is how
similar are the different corona virus
viruses and what are the chances that
the wildlife hosts are tracking over
time is misidentified due to convergent
evolution I'm not a hundred percent sure
what they're asking but I think I can
answer it generally we're not and so
there's a big diversity of corona
viruses and they vary in a bunch of
different ways one of the major
differences amongst the different
viruses is important is the part of
their genome and that's what's on the
outside of the virus and it's what helps
it connect off with human cells and for
the virus to be able to inject its DNA
into those cells so there's lots of
differences amongst the different
viruses one of the things that's been
found is that the pieces of the genome
that encode that can scan to recombine
because the different viruses multiple
viruses may be in the same host and they
can sort of swap parts and the right
swapping of parts together can produce
the combination that is ideal for
connecting up with a nother animals or
humans selves using that using that
spiked protein so you have a very large
pool of viruses and these different
parts amongst them and sort of chance
events let them recombine with each
other and there's a lot we don't know
about this you know it can happen
differently in the bat population versus
as other you know like domestic or other
trading animals that perhaps the virus
is a in an intermediate stage before
getting to humans but it's really sort
of this recombination and like it's sort
of generality is one of the things that
makes these different coronaviruses and
the big pool of them a real big
potential source for new viruses that
can infect humans so that means you're
saying there's a lot of them and
probably a lot we haven't discovered yes
there are definitely a lot we haven't
discovered that number sort of estimated
is all over the plates you know when you
think about all viruses that could
infect humans there have been estimates
that have come out that are in the
millions there are reasons to think
that's much smaller because of sort of
sampling bias approaches there are
reasons to think it's much bigger
because viruses are constantly evolving
and changing over time but there's
definitely a big pool of viruses that
are unknown and potential other sources
of infection and doing things like being
better at how we interact with wildlife
you know potentially you know being able
to do more early surveillance and human
populations that interact with those
wildlife you know you know and sort of
creating more of this sort of early
warning system for those type of things
and understanding more of those viruses
by sampling in the wild altogether can
make it less likely that we'll be
surprised again
I apologize for that noise I was getting
zoom bond by a one-year-old he was
having a lot of fun watching your talk
so someone's asking a question about the
different strains and you already talked
about the different strains that we know
they're different ones but what point do
the different strains become different
viruses can they mutate that far or the
only ghosts just become strains and
what's the difference being a strain and
a whole new virus so it's a tough
question that you know virus is more
than other species it's much harder to
draw the line because they reproduce so
differently
you know you don't sort of get this
clear definition of you know these
viruses can interact with these and
these cans and so you know the nation
notion of a clade or a strain or a
species is very fuzzy but it's also
important to know that you can have that
mutation is a very normal part of
viruses even if they're not changing in
any significant way
so those evolutionary trees especially
on something like next string which
shows all of these different you know
all of this variation in those viruses
most of those differences are in genes
or single nucleotides and genes that
don't really have any effect on the
virus
so like different groups of virus at
this point in our understanding they you
know they might help us identify sort of
like where a particular outbreak has
come from but there's not yet any
evidence that those viruses are
functionally different in any way um
coronaviruses like this they like have
that regular mutation you know the big
changes that have occurred in them seem
to be partially due to that sort of
recombination and swapping which is more
the case when you have multiple viruses
in the same host and you know sort of
the real big question is not if the
virus is going to change really in a big
functional way but how it might evolve
in relation to an eventual vaccine
because one of the things that we see in
flu viruses is that when you have a
vaccine the flu viruses that drives
evolution in the flu viruses and then
the new viruses you have in the future
are a little less responsive to that
vaccine which means you need to update
the vaccine and so it's a big open
question as to how that will play out
with the corona virus previous corona
viruses it's not been as big of an issue
but we don't know about this one yet I
imagine that's something that's being
studied to try to figure out how it will
mutate just like they study how the flu
will mutate right I don't think we're
anywhere near there yet
in understanding that this is we don't
have
a vaccine or even a real good
understanding of immunization and
people's gain of immunity and reaction
to it but that's something that many
people are very closely tracking in
looking at the genetic sequences of the
virus and how they will change over time
once treatments are introduced and I
actually just brought up a good point
I've saw an article going around it's so
hard to know what's true and what isn't
just once being posted on random
people's pages but has there been any
vaccines for any corona viruses before
would this be the first time we
successfully done that ah let me guess
so we have had so corona viruses that
have emerged there has been the last
SARS something called Elyse turn
respiratory syndrome and then there are
a few widely circulating human
coronaviruses that are largely
associated with common colds I do not
believe there is an active vaccine for
any of those both SARS and MERS have
largely we can control via other
measures of Earth continues to be an
issue and the other human coronaviruses
haven't been as you know they just like
haven't been as damaging and haven't
been as big of a problem so sort of an
active vaccine I do not think there has
been that said because of the
understanding because of MERS and
sorrows and the likelihood that there
would be more corona viruses this is
something you know like for instance
that barrack lab I mentioned you know
has started so um the there isn't a
previous corona vet virus vaccine um but
most indications are that you know an
active vaccine program will be able to
produce one and we hope it'll you know
we produce soon and it's just why is
this corona virus so much more damaging
than the previous ones it's not
something we totally know it's something
that there's um and you know sort of the
molecular side of this is less my
expertise so I'm sure there's some
people out there who will you know
comment otherwise but you know the you
know the this virus is it has a lower
fatality rate
previous coronaviruses but is much more
transmissible one of the things that
maybe contributed to that
transmissibility is it's spiked protein
that protein on the outside of the virus
that binds to your cells actually binds
much more strongly so it may be that
that binding is part of it and so it's
more easily transmitted once it's in you
like it's more likely to actually take
hold it may be due to differences in
transmission if it survives a little
better you know or a little differently
outside the human host and the other
ones that could be part of it um you
know and all of those things combined
you know it can be like small a sort of
a set of small marginal changes a set of
small marginal changes of how the immune
system reacts to it and how it is able
to defend itself against the immune
system that all add up and then that top
level it's really about that super-high
transmissibility that results from those
combined changes and that's why it's
been so much more damaging than other
corona viruses that we've seen it's
there's been a few questions here about
how can people contribute either through
doing work or the datasets and I believe
you'll point us to the our consortium
site by there is that the best place for
people to go to help both with time and
data and anything else they can do I
think so I mean that sites are
relatively new so it's going to we think
it's going to expand a bunch of
specially with the our consortium coming
in to help with the the our consortium
to help with our at the death epidemic
consortium so I definitely point you to
that first although one of the reasons I
point you to that is that in my
experience the people who really like
need a little bit of support they're
like the big groups doing you know like
sort of high-level modeling but often
you know if you live in a community
where you know you know people are
thinking about you know where they're
our first response errs and like one
Hospital and you know small groups often
the capacity just for managing data and
handling data and doing that kind of
thing is not as big as the
and say like the New York Department of
Public Health it's planning that's doing
a lot of planning and it's been my
experience that a lot of requests from
help have come from small groups like
that kind of flowing around and someone
who can just you know organize
spreadsheets and make graphs and keep
them up is often helpful but it's hard
to connect with those right you have to
sort of have that connection with your
community and so if you do have that
type of connection I'd encourage you to
find it otherwise the best thing that I
know is the our consortium for now but I
think something we will try to do is
post more links and connections to other
groups to make sure that we're pointing
people to other resources and please
people that do make use of the Kovan 19
channel post in there and get help in
there and offer help in there too
because this is a big community of data
scientists and epidemiologists I'm sure
there's a lot of them amongst us besides
just know them another question was how
do you analyze DNA sequences do you
tokenize the sequences and analyze
relationships so that's a big question
and I guess emphasized like my mind most
of my work is in that big geospatial
stuff in the dynamic stuff and there are
many many ways to analyze those DNA
sequences there are contexts in which
tokenization is used you know there are
like some being sort of machine learning
approaches especially when you're
working with full genomes and trying to
do prediction off those people will do
sort of clustering and tokenization
algorithms in order to reduce those down
and use them in a regressions but when
you're doing this sort of stuff like the
phylogenetics that builds off the
evolutionary sort of structures to build
the model and those processes
you really are handling those of the
individual nucleotide level deserve one
that one letter in the string or short
groups of those that represent single
proteins or single genes and so it
really is sort of a specialized and then
when it you know when it comes to being
like well let's take a genetic sequence
and do a big machine learning approach
to to
prediction then that often does fall
into many things that are more familiar
to broader scientists you know there is
work that's been done essentially taking
an entire genomes genome sequences and
doing giant logistic regression
regression on every nucleotide you know
it's not always you know some of that is
sort of hand wavy work that isn't as
useful but some of its good and so there
a lot of the techniques that are used to
reduce those models which otherwise
would be overly large with overly wide
data people he was like vowel rabbit
which is a I think I forget Microsoft or
a Facebook project John Lankford yeah
you know to do like massive mostly
logistic regression people have thrown
that at the genetic data or things like
you know
GLM net yep genetic data to essentially
or tried to deal with many no turning
those sequences into many many variables
that are you going into that really sort
of genomic specific software and models
and Glenda was actually invented for
genomics actually that's some AC
Tribbiani did it specifically
specifically for that
and I just posted a link to the the
slack channel for John Lankford's talk
about football a bit about a year ago at
the meetup so people want to find that
that's over there I see that Michael
just posted the actual presentation
itself to the chat over here and Michael
that's not up on the meetup website the
actual PDF so you could put that up
there that'd be really awesome too
let me see if there's any other
questions here someone's asking what are
some good resources to learn about
epidemiology and public health like
books websites what other resources you
have beside your excellent talk where
can they go learn more oh man that's big
I'm not gonna have a you know one of the
things about epidemiology is it's such a
big field you sort of remember you know
we have this focus especially now on
infectious disease epidemiologists and
you know these particular types of
models and piggle type of folk
but epidemiology is the study you know
of health in populations and disease
ecology of health and populations of
wild animals and plants so some
epidemiologists are thinking about you
know air pollution burdens on people and
some are thinking about cancers and some
are thinking about transmissible stuff
like influences and kovat and AIDS so
it's a very big topic so to some degree
sort of diving in to something more
specific is often the case so I could
probably post some good ideas about
where to learn things about like you
know these infectious disease dynamical
dynamical OTE models that people could
look at and you know some of the not
just the models but the understand lying
principles and theories and I'll I'll
come up with some and add them but when
it comes to epidemiology you know it's
you know it says big a field with
anything else you know trying to learn
about biology or learn about physics um
it's often very helpful to figure out
you know the smaller the smaller piece
to chew yeah there's a lot there so
maybe you just post you know some of
your favorites like you know you did the
landmarks like elements assist the
equivalent of elements of statistical
learning if you think of one pose it to
the slack channel right dan chen i'm
specifically calling out his name
because he isn't does bioinformatics
asked with all these resources where as
a point of no return where we have too
many and therefore data overloaded and
can't make meaning out of it all we are
simultaneously way past that and not far
enough you know in the sense that like
there is lots and lots of every every
day there's more data on kovat and
there's lots of this on the other hand
there's still a lot of data we don't
have you know like one of the big things
that's hopefully coming online and you
know the next few weeks is people doing
antibody tests and there being data
coming out from antibody tests of people
that helps us understand who has
previously gotten the disease so who
might have gotten the disease that don't
have haven't had symptoms or have had
flu-like symptoms but don't know if it
was kovat or not and sort of let it pass
without being tested themselves for the
live Kovan so
you know that type of information is
going to be you know useful at the same
time then there's just this flood of
stuff if you follow the scientific
literature it's been fantastically you
know rapid and fast and in terms of the
rate at which we've learned about this
disease and the rate of which we are
reporting about it it's like nothing
else that you know has happened in any
other epidemic and even you know people
who spend all of the time thinking about
this can't keep up with it
so what's really helpful is often the
people now who are writing the reviews
and the summaries and the the aggregates
of of things I've come to rely on those
a lot speaking of which we just had a
question what would you say to people
who aren't experts in the field but
they're trying to play the data to make
sense of it and model the future spread
of the virus I got to make definitive
statements about how we'll progress I
mean I don't think we can ever we can
never make definitive statements you
know we can tend to make statements of
more and less probability and you know
I'm not one to think that you know like
only an epidemiologist should are on
such a model or that only certain types
of science to do certain types of work
that I think you know if you're trying
to play with the data and learn with it
and you want to help others learn and
get insight with it the best thing to do
is to try to engage with others who have
different types of expertise in the
field right so people who are not you
know whose main expertise was not in
epidemiology or certain types of medical
expertise have made sort of great
contributions to the science but it's
best done it really in dialogue so I'd
say if you've like pulled something up
and played with it and you have like
what you think is our really interesting
insight it's a really good idea to see
if you can find someone to like bounce
that off on who has direct field
expertise or you know or you know at
least has worked in the related area
because you'll have your own biases from
your your areas of expertise and your
fields and they'll have different ones
and
people can help people you know make you
know catch problems that come up or they
know something about the origin of the
data that might not be immediate obvious
or they might know something about
principles in the field of this either
you know support or clashes with and you
have to figure out why or if something
needs to change in your work or the
principles and so I think it's great for
people to grab work with this data play
with this data
sherry share with each other the type of
work but if you want to if you think you
like have something that you want to
make a big statement about cuz you found
something it's something that you really
should make an effort to collaborate
first because that sort of helps cut
down the noise for a lot of people and
helps people finds you know find
mistakes before they can cause a problem
or result in some misinterpretation or
misinformation I think that's a very
good point of Rob Heineman who is a
world famous times your time series and
forecasting expert put out a blog post a
week or two ago saying you can't just
use the regular time series models for
this univariate time series models even
multivariate because it's so much more
than just a time series model time
series is great when we don't know
underlying processes but fortunately
that 'buddy me ology there's other
information we can put in there and you
just don't want to look at deaths by day
or or infections by day because you're
missing out so much more so really think
about the methods and don't just go for
like a it's over time looks like a time
series you've got thinking about spatial
God thing but all the EPI stuff so
really collaborate as no one was saying
we have more questions coming in about
how can they contribute if data and
again you've mentioned that the our
consortium that a kovat resources site
which I'm later if you could post a link
to slack channel it'd be great for
everyone to have that so why don't we
make one once you pick one more question
Jared all right got it so there's
actually a follow up from what you said
earlier about the phylogenetic modeling
and about which drugs might work against
kovat like for instance if cove is in
the same cluster as drugs for which hdq
has worked before would that give good
evidence
shakeela work again this is chic you the
farthest from my expertise of any
question we've had alright let me ask
you a different one then I'll all just
I'll get I'll give it so that so the
short answer is I really don't know on
that front but to the extent it's like a
way that people help identify candidates
it it does happen but it tends to happen
much you know further upstream the
phylogenetics help you sort of think
about whether the you know do tests
about whether the viruses work the same
way and then you know the tests would
have come later right but I couldn't
tell you more than that
they're enough if you do one more since
I couldn't fit fair enough
another was just asking about wise
transmission so high in the northeast of
the United States and yeah let's just go
that is like is it too much to be higher
in the Northeast and other places and is
there a good reason besides density in
New York City well you know there's a
lot of theories about this it's the kind
of thing you think you can have very
intuitive reasons and it's tough to
figure out why if people think about
density and the different nature of the
cities you know and but another
important thing can be timing of
policies you know to our understanding
West Coast cities were able to enact you
know shelter in place and you know pause
and social distinct policies earlier in
the epidemic than elsewhere and so
that's one possibility
you know density is density is another
possibility as well one early
possibility is maybe that a lot more
people with the disease were showing up
earlier and that actually Jareau of
early growth more than we knew so these
are all possibilities that's something
we're looking at the fair bid a fair bit
now it's very important in understanding
the the approaches to managing disease
in the future but the density question
is one that's still out is still out to
be answered there's some evidence that
that type of thing has made differences
and other diseases in the past but not
in this
sadly as much as one as one might think
so I want to say thank you very much to
Nome I hope we all have a sort of
measure comfort in our lives seeing that
people like Nome are working on this and
really putting in the best effort to
solve this problem hopefully get a speck
normalcy normally this point I tell
everyone to give a big round of applause
for you but you won't hear it
so just everyone imagine I hope we're
all applauding no I'm at home
individually and it's nice and raucous
and very thankful for that so everyone
else you can absolutely go ask questions
in the psych Channel maybe later
tomorrow gnomes not so tired he'll be
able to hop in there a little bit use
the cove in 1900 as other resources and
stay tuned for next month's meetup we
will continue and have another talk
about coronavirus because we'll odds are
good we might still be back on our back
in our homes I'll be nice if we're not
meantime just thank you very much to
Nomo everyone has a wonderful night or
evening or day or afternoon or morning
wherever you are and see you around
virtually in the our community have a
great great rest of your time thank you
know Thank You Jared and thank you
everybody I see a lot of people clapping
in the comments for you so great job
Nome